يشاركني الحديث في اا هذه الزاويه المحامي
عبد الرحمن اللحم حياك الله ما عرفنا شجره
الراس
حراك تشريعي كبير جدا هذا العام في
السعوديه همم اربعه انظمه اعلانات
تشريعيه في مقدماتها طبعا نظام الاحوال
الشخصيه ونظام الاثبات ما الذي اضافته
للتشريعات السعوديه في 2022
اااا اعتقد انه عمل فيه 22 سنه عامه في
المملكه
وانا اسميه ده اسميه همم انه عام بدايه
التقنين لانه صدر فيه همم كما ذكرت اخوي
نايف همم
النظامين مهمين وهي احد الانظمه الاربعه
التي اعلن عنها الامير محمد بن سلمان بن
عبد العزيز
الاحوال الشخصيه اثبات
انظمه محوريه
وسدده
في همم في السابق وفوق ذلك وقبل ذلك ان
انتهت جدر
الكبير تاريخي اضعنا اعمارنا فيه وهو
مواجهه
المعارضين للتقنيم الذين كانوا عطلوا
الحراك ااا
التشريعي والتطور التشريعي في المملكه
طوال العقود من الزمن في تاريخ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا اصبح من التاريخ
يعني في هذه السنه من خلال هذه الانظمه
الاساسيه ايضا هناك انظمه اخرى لا تقل
اهميه عنها وهي مثلا نظام الشركات
خلق قوالب وافكار تشريعيه غير مسبوقه في
العالم وهذه الحركه التشريعي ليس فقط
بالكم وانما ايضا بالكيف يعني
القوانين
مصاغه على اسس ونظريات قانونيه متقدمه
صنعت يعني مدرسه تشجيعيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مستقله من الاول نحن كنا
يعني انظر تقليديه ناخذ من الدول التي
صداقه في هذا المجال
تبني عليه
يعني حراك
ابو خالد هذا العام ارتفاع نسبه مشاركتها
كذلك ايضا حتى في سوق العمل اكثر من 35 في
همم المئه لكن الجديد في هذا العام هو
الدخول في الوظائف القضائيه كيف يمكن
النظر اليه
طبعا
التمثيل المراه هو جاء يعني في هذه السنه
متميز جدا لان المراه تولت مناصب قياديه
على اعلى المستويات يعني
كصوابق تاريخيه في المملكه ايضا كما اشرت
اخوي نايف انه
المراه دخلت
المؤسسات القرائيه ممثله في النيابه
العامه النيابه العامه هي سباقه في هذا
المجال واتاحت همم للمراه ان تعمل محققه
وهي وظيفه قضائيه لاول مره في تاريخ
المملكه
وتمنى انه انه يعني يتبعها العديد من من
من من
هذه الخطوات الجريئه التي تتوام مع رؤيه
المملكه عندي دقيقه وارغب بالسؤال عن
الحدث
الاهم هذا العام في السعوديه 2022 في ما
يخص همم سواء التشريعات او حتى ايضا
الاحداث الاجتماعيه في السعوديه
اعتقد من حيث من ناحيه من ناحيه الترشيات
كما ذكرت يعني
التشييع الاحوال الشخصيه على وجه التحديد
اعتقد انه حدث محوري ومهم جدا لانه يعالج
قضايا كبيره ولها مساس في جراحه واسعه من
المجتمع
فاول كان في تضارب بالاحكام كان يعني
ضبابيه في في
الجوانب القانونيه لكن الان انتهت هذه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مع همم كان معنا هنا في
الاستديو طبعا المحامي عبد الرحمن